what's a dragon that's a dragon
i Maximo from FX guide.com
for Wired well whether digital in New
Zealand know a thing or two about
fire-breathing dragons having done the
Hobbit with the desolation of smaug but
perhaps a new a little bit less about
the furry vanishing kind that is until
director david lowery feats dragon came
to New Zealand well the film begins in
the Pacific Northwest somewhere in the
recent past my new we need is something
special for the story for the characters
and I had sneaky suspicion we'd find
that in New Zealand
you
Oh
Pete's dragon Elliott presented some
real challenges to the visual effects
team chief among them was this idea of
Elliott's invisibility during the course
of the film the nature of this changes
depending on kind of the emotion of the
scene now in some scenes such as this
Elliott is effectively camouflaged and
other times he's actually invisible in
other words sometimes the whehter
artists needed Elliott to appear to have
the texture of the background on him and
at other times we need to sort of have
the idea that we're seeing through him
to the forest beyond now the camouflage
was mainly used in the earlier scenes
whenever Elliott has a texture on him
when he moves he's incredibly readable
it's actually served a fairly
interesting purpose for when Elliott
gets angry you see the dragon has some
twenty-eight custom grooms of over 20
million individual hairs and they were
all simulated quite separately so as the
camouflage texture was projected on them
in 3d if for example his fur blew in the
wind the camouflage would kind of break
up the team latched onto this then used
it when Elliott gets angry giving the
idea that he was kind of losing his
camouflage when he was losing his cool
this particular shop was the first one
that the team did of the invisibility
and it comes at the end of the film is
quite sad and the problem here is unlike
the camouflage sequences how do you
actually read where a giant invisible
creature actually is the team solved
this by adding kind of particles and
flock to the air the disturbance of the
still forest air gives the very elegant
solution that the director wanted
without introducing anything that's kind
of magical or breaks the rather somber
and sad tone at this point in the film
while the film had been previous by
proof in LA the filmmakers opted to not
have practical stuff happening on set
but wherever you see the dragon
interacting with something be that trees
undergrowth or plants that will also
fall at it digitally in post
oscar-nominated visual effects
supervisor Eric sand and actually joined
Pete's dragon directly from The Hobbit
where to actually help redesign the
character a bit by making the nose more
horse light apparently horses have very
expressive noses as well as working on
the ears bringing them down on the side
of the head making them less cat-like
and more like that of a dog and if
you're wondering how you kind of get
young actors to give a really good
performance when they're effectively
meant to be working with what is after
all kind of a giant fly green furry pet
dog Erik Sandin himself walked around on
set with a giant 20 foot pole with a
ball on the end of it he actually acted
out the role of Elliot in the film all
this comes together in a really complex
retelling of the 1977 Disney classic
please don't forget subscribe for more
behind the scenes action I might see
more for why